فيديو مرعب من الرحلة 328 على متن
الطائرة
يُظهر المحرك الصحيح
يشتعل فجأة كان هناك صوت مرتفع
ثم أصبح سيئًا
حقًا اعتقدت أن البرق ضرب الطائرة في
البداية ، كان هناك انفجار كبير
ونوع الصوت الذي لا تريده  أريد أن
أسمع عندما تكون على متن طائرة
ووضعت ظلي على الفور
وكنت خائفًا جدًا من
رؤية المحرك على جانبي كان يفتقد
إلى طائرة بوينج 777 التي كانت تسافر من دنفر إلى هونولولو
تعاني من
عطل في المحرك بعد دقائق من الإقلاع ،
نظرنا إلى كل منها  أنا وزوجتي الأخرى
وتمسكت بأيدينا
وتمنيت فقط لأطفالنا أن يراهم
مرة أخرى.
لا أعرف من هم شهود العيان
على الأرض وهم يرون قطعًا من الطائرة
تتساقط من السماء
في ضواحي دنفر في مقاطعة برومفيلد
بأمانة في ملعب كرة السلة فقط
استمتع بالطائرة وهي تحلق عالياً حقًا
، وما بدا وكأنه دوي صوتي
جعل الجميع ينظرون لأعلى كما فعلنا يمكننا
أن نرى أن
هناك سحابة سوداء عملاقة من الدخان
عالياً في  السماء
تليها على الفور تعرف ما
يبدو وكأنه قطع من الطائرة
تنطلق للتو ، وهي عبارة عن
وابل
من الأشياء التي كانت تتساقط من
السماء ، وانتشر حقل الحطام على مسافة ميل واحد
وفقًا لشرطة المكنسة ، اخترقت
قطع معدنية ضخمة
لسقف متناثر فوقها.  ملعب كرة قدم
ومروج كنت أنا وزوجتي جالسين
داخل المنزل
انتهينا للتو من
الورق وسمعنا هذا الانفجار
الكبير ونظرنا إلى بعضنا البعض وذهبنا إلى ما
كان عليه
ثم حدث أيضًا انفجار في حادث
و
يتدحرج هذا الكائن أمام
منزلنا مباشرةً خارج النافذة الأمامية ،
لذلك أقوم وألقي نظرة إلى الخارج
وأحاول معرفة ما هو عليه ، وبمجرد
أن أفتح الباب ، أذهب ، إنه
جزء محرك
كان  بعد الساعة الواحدة ظهرًا بالتوقيت المحلي ، عندما
أعلن طيار 777
وعلى متنها 241 شخصًا في يوم
طارئ ،
قام
28328 طائرة استغاثة
ثقيلة ، و 320 إقامة ثقيلة ضدها مرة أخرى ،
نعم تعرف دنفر أه
رحيل  المتحدة 328 طائرة استغاثة ثقيلة
لمجرد تجربة
الشعور بالفشل ، فأنت بحاجة إلى الانعطاف
على الفور ، حيث كان الطاقم
تحت السيطرة
والهبوط بأمان في
مطار دنفر الدولي ، كانت ابنتي
جالسة على النافذة وهي
تعرف أنني كنت مثل لا  يبدو
أننا دعنا نغلقها ودعونا نصلي فقط ، وهذا ما فعلناه ، لقد
تشبثنا بأيدينا وقلنا بعض
الصلوات ، لقد أخذنا بعض الوقت للصلاة
مع بعضنا البعض وكان هناك أشخاص من
حولي يصلون ولكني شعرت
بالثقة في أننا  كانوا في
طريقهم للعودة إلى المطار وفقًا
للوحدة ، لم يتعرض أي من الركاب أو الطاقم
لأي إصابات ، وبشكل لا يصدق لم يصب
أحد على الأرض
في هذه الحديقة في يوم مثل
اليوم عندما لم يكن الجو باردًا كما كان
في نهاية الأسبوع الماضي  مئات
الأشخاص
هنا وحقيقة أننا ما زلنا لا
نتلقى تقارير عن أي إصابات
أمر صادم للغاية في هذه المرحلة ،
حيث يتم نقل
الحطام المذهل من الطائرة النفاثة التالفة
إلى اليوم التالي.  enver airport لتحليل
مجلس سلامة النقل الوطني
تحقق FAA و Boeing